okay yeah now I'll be the first to admit
that the shampoo might have been
overkill hey first we feast Shawn here
coming at you from Los Angeles where I'm
joined by Michael Stevens that's right
Michael has invited us to Vsauce HQ and
as I'm sure you know already
Vsauce it's one of the biggest best
channels on YouTube breaking down the
scientific mysteries of the universe hey
Vsauce Michael here eating your own
boogers is gross but it might be smart
and today we're turning that microscope
on to me because I am about a hundred
hot ones interviews in and I need to
figure out a hotsauce antidote and
figure one out now before my insides
spontaneously combust on YouTube of all
places we've gathered up some of the
hottest meals in Los Angeles we're gonna
pair them with common remedies and then
to bring it full circle Michael has made
us a very special cocktail of his own a
sundae to fight the capsaicin the
capsaicin the capsaicin what is it it's
a molecule it's the active ingredient in
Chili Peppers that makes them harm us
mammals not birds birds don't even
notice it because for evolutionary
reasons these peppers probably didn't
really care for its ate them because
birds would swallow their seeds whole
poop them out cover the nutrients and
then they grow but mammals have grinding
teeth we destroy those seeds and they
can't grow so you better build a
protection against us hence the pain the
spice if I eat a wing doused with debt
sauce with liquid rage
what's going on in my body exactly
capsaicin is gonna bind to a receptor on
your tongue in your mouth and it's a
vanilla receptor that also responds to
heat abrasion pain when this molecule
binds with it it signals the brain hey
I'm being activated I'm dumb though I'm
just this neuron receptor I don't really
know what it means but the brain goes
whenever you send me a signal it's bad
it's paying its heat and so you actually
feel those thing
even though there is no damage or heat
occurring it's an endless topic of
fascination with our commenters I'm
always seeing things about why do you
have water on the table everybody has
all these remedies for me personally
maybe it's just psychological but
there's something about that ice water
that when I take it it gives me this
temporary relief it's an alkaline oil
capsaicin is ways to combat it generally
involve attacking it those two
properties you want to find a way to
make a oil actually become a solution
with something it won't do that with
water you also want to attack the
alkaline nature so add in an acid water
can make it worse why because it is
polar and so it's not gonna create a
solution with oils like capsaicin so
instead it just pushes it around and it
pushes those molecules that are causing
you pain to other parts of your mouth
resulting in more pain cold water I get
why that would help that cooling that
coldness probably does register as a
pleasant sensation but I think there are
things that will work better well let's
put those things to the test up first we
have cochinita tacos linguist ah dose
it's gonna be a shredded pork thing with
some habanero chili and then to fight it
we have olive oil yeah scientifically
what does olive oil do for you the
mechanism by which it's supposed to help
with the spice is that it is an oil it's
a fat so it should be able to create a
solution with the oil that is the
capsaicin so what I think we should do
is you know take a bite once we feel
ready to combat that spice take a little
bit of a sip and then use it just like
mouthwash really get it all the way
around your mouth even gargle it if you
want get it between your teeth and then
spit it out mmm so really good oh that's
a slow build that's why gentleman and
slowly I think the more attention you
pay to it the worse it is that is
totally true yeah that's totally true
and you zero in on it it exaggerated sit
so let's shock the sit here Cheers
[Music]
man that was gross okay but it worked
pretty well what do you think yeah I am
actually
surprised at how it has taken that
sensation away not sure though if it's a
net positive because I do now in my
mouth that feels like an old attic I
guess I shouldn't be surprised it's what
the chemistry says should happen but
there's a reason restaurants don't give
you a cup of olive oil to help yourself
with spicy foods it's disgusting
alright so up next we have the El Diablo
burger from hot daddy and here we have
serrano chiles we have habanero we have
totally Mayo it's a whole grab bag here
and then to combat it we have some
90-proof from yeah what is it about
alcohol that saves you when you're on
fire
alcohol can dissolve capsaicin unlike
water it's not a polar solvent we've got
a lot of alcohol in here but like half
of its water however it might be enough
[Music]
hmm
right away major heat but I can feel the
endorphins pumping out that's the thing
you just start to come alive a little
bit you really start to feel it you
settle in get a little buzz going and
then yeah before you even had any rum
you feel that life because you feel like
you're close to death Cheers okay I feel
worse I feel a lot worse like just on a
heat level I actually feel like it's
exaggerated
yeah the heat and my mouth more it's
like a cut and then you put alcohol on
it and it stings my work feels worse now
and the good flavors of the burger have
been replaced with Rama and it's just
like I don't want this I mean the rum
should have helped in some way
but again half of it is water it might
not be a strong enough proof ah I'm
looking I'm looking for agate what water
man's gonna clean out my insides later
it's up next we have the ghost chili
lamb vindaloo from Bad mosh you have
serrano chiles you have red chilies then
of course the ghost pepper and then to
counteract it we have lemons well lemons
contain a lot of water so we have to be
a little bit careful it's not gonna help
dissolve the oil but water can move
molecules around even if it can't
dissolve them but these lemons have a
liquid in sight that's also very acidic
and because capsaicin is alkaline they
might be able to neutralize each other
so I'm thinking literally suck on a
lemon like just wrap your lips and
around get all that juice out you have
to swallow it
mmm I'm still affected by that burger
the rum was like oh yeah you think this
burgers bad we'll try it everywhere what
do you think you know when the heat hits
you and it's very scratchy in your
throat that's what I have right now I
have some sweat on my forehead I'm
reacting to this physically more than I
have any other dish so did you take a
bite of the pepper just took a bite out
of the tip that wasn't a good idea
all right you go for that I'm gonna go
for one of these whole halves here
respect it I love it
[Music]
so whoa I think it did a pretty good job
you know I'm feeling pretty good and I
also feel like fresh like I just had you
know I was like lemonade really my nose
is starting to run a little bit got a
little eyebrow sweat but I'm not sure if
that's you know the vindaloo the lemon
are just the cumulative effects of
everything that we've done today
we've been swallowing this food so it's
still affecting us on the inside and
we've been breathing and that's putting
it on all or other mucous membranes and
our nose so yeah I mean we still are
sweating and snotty but our mouths are
ready to keep fighting
[Music]
so this is the last dab it's the tenth
wing sauce on half once so we're gonna
need to pull out all the stops for this
one and as I understand it you have a
little secret weapon or your own I'm
ready I'm ready it's gonna be an
experiment though I haven't tried this
before but I'm gonna combine everything
we know about capsaicin and try to
combat it from every angle we'll each
have a dish and in this dish we're gonna
start with vanilla bean gelato
a nice mild gelato but that's got a lot
of fat in it a lot of dairy fat we know
can help dissolve the capsaicin because
it's the right kind of solvent but then
the dairy contains casein which also
acts in our favor as a detergent it'll
help the capsaicin actually dissolve in
water I'm gonna add some honey honey has
sugar in it but honey's also actually
quite acidic and that acid like the
lemons should help neutralize the
alkaline oil of the capsaicin
next up saltine crackers I think what
its gonna do is act as a mop it's going
to absorb a lot of liquid once we've
dissolved the capsaicin oil in our
mouths we want something to soak them up
finally I talked about the casein in the
dairy being a detergent that helps water
and oil mix let's just use a real
detergent baby shampoo it seemed like
the most edible of the shampoos on the
market I recommend not actually
swallowing I don't think it'll kill you
but it might have a bit of a diarrhea
inducing effect we've got the detergents
to get water and oil to mix we've got
the saltines to soak up what we create
we've got the casein as a detergent
we've got the fat in the ice cream and
the coldness of the ice cream actually
gelato I think all that'll be very very
soothing all right so let's see who are
up against what I'm gonna do here
Michael is I'm gonna put a DAB on the
wing just like we would on the show I'm
also gonna put a little puddle on the
side just because I think that it's
important that we get the sauce get the
real flavor
thank you there you go you ready let's
do here's Cheers I don't
I think you've invented something great
here I think it shouldn't really be
edible before we take a bite mm-hmm I
want to sit with this spice for a little
bit
I just want to meditate on it I just
want to concentrate on the mouthing it's
an existential experience it's not
pleasant dude like I wouldn't hang out
with friends and eat this around them
because I don't want to engage with
people
[Music]
hmm okay I almost puked I'll say this I
feel like I just took a shower and it is
very much that shampoo that is the
secret ingredient that is probably
dominating the best eye I think you know
my lips are still on fire I'm gonna I'm
gonna put a little on my lips yeah put
some on your lips mmm you know what
that's not bad I'll tell you what this
shampoo I thought it would be a lot
grosser than it is No
like just on a taste level it's
manageable it's much better than the rum
right now I feel like it's uh it's a
heavyweight bout in my mouth it's a
battle because the roof of my mouth is
still burning
it definitely cured the tongue I think I
could keep using this and get better let
me actually just try this man it is not
bad okay yeah now I'll be the first to
admit that the shampoo might have been
overkill here's what I want to say to
bring it all full circle I want to give
you a big first we feast
pat on the back because this really is a
cocktail that can bring you back to life
and then even to you know the shampoo
maybe it was overkill but maybe not
because I feel so fresh spicy heat is is
quite psychological if you tell someone
dude baby shampoo cures it totally that
can go a long way to making it work even
better if they truly believe that
there's science behind that which
they're kind of is it's a detergent I
think it makes them feel better like
it's under control part of the panic
with spicy foods like this is that you
feel like it's only going to get worse
and I already can barely breathe I'm in
trouble so there you have it don't act
like we never did anything for you
and if you're interested in the video
you're interested in science or
interested in learning new things
Michael gets the Curiosity box videos
they only go so far
sometimes you need to go to the real
thing make sure you check out vsauce
minefield season 2 coming out soon you
already know thanks Sean I went through
it's been an honor thank you appreciate
it man
[Music]
you
[Music]